este 8 de junio es la fecha señalada por
el ejército zapatista de liberación
nacional el ezln para llevar a cabo esta
jornada global de protesta y exigir que
cese lo que ellos consideran es la
guerra contra las comunidades zapatistas
el pasado 22 de mayo de este año ocurrió
un ataque con armas de fuego en la
comunidad Moisés Gandhi que está en
ococingo Y en este ataque fue herido de
gravedad nuestro compañero Jorge López
santis el cual Pues sigue hospitalizado
y Bueno pues esta agresión se enmarca en
una serie de
de ataques violentos en contra de las
comunidades zapatistas que llevan ya
muchos años la última semana de mayo
pobladores del municipio de frontera
Comalapa vivieron días de terror la
violencia derivada de la disputa por el
territorio entre el cartel Jalisco Nueva
Generación y el cartel de Sinaloa
provocó balaceras amenazas y
reclutamiento forzado por ello cerca de
mil habitantes se vieron obligados al
desplazamiento forzado vemos que el
crimen organizado y sus distintos
negocios trata de mujeres trata de
personas venta de drogas venta de armas
prostitución está ya penetrando las
comunidades indígenas un fenómeno que no
habíamos visto antes en el país la
situación en el estado es delicada el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
ha dicho que se han desplegado ya a
elementos de las fuerzas federales para
resguardar el orden pero que hay bases
social del crimen organizado dice que
hay pobladores que apoyan a los
criminales Lo cierto es que quienes
están padeciendo esta situación de
violencia son los niños las mujeres los
adultos mayores en las comunidades
zapatistas por esto Esta convocatoria
apoyada por personalidades como
Gael García el actor
buscan despertar la conciencia y dicen
que van a seguir defendiendo a las
comunidades zapatistas
[Música]
Chiapas aguanta el pueblo se